[Musique]
ce sont les diamants de sochaux les plus
beaux bijoux de famille de la marque au
lion
mais l'objectif ce jour là n'était pas
vraiment la visite d'un musée
[Musique]
et cette balade donc cabriolet 504
n'avait qu'un but découvrir
l'intégralité d'un trésor caché là
quelque part dans le pays de montbéliard
[Musique]
alors là je vais vous emmener dans un
endroit un peu secret c'est les réserves
du musée de l'aventuré peugeot les
collections du musée c'est environ 650
voitures hors dans le musée en
permanence nous en exposons que 120 et
hervé charpentier est l'un des
conservateurs de l'aventuré peugeot l'un
des rares ici à avoir la clé d'un
immense coffre à jouets unique au monde
personne ne peut rentrer ici à part
c'est un lieu qui est réservée à
quelques personnes c'est un lieu de vie
au travail au stockage n'a pas vocation
à être visitables
[Musique]
donc ici nous sommes dans une travée un
peu spéciale puisque c'est vraiment le
coin dévolu aux voitures de compétition
ici on va retrouver un peu plus de 100
ans
l'histoire de la marque dans les
différents rallyes raid alors bien
entendu la plupart des véhicules que
vous voyez là sont dans l'ère moderne
puisque les principaux véhicules de
compétition anciens sont dans les
collections permanentes
tu nous aides aventure peugeot
soigneusement rangés sur quatre étages
on trouve dans ce hangar des véhicules
mythiques des prototypes mais aussi des
modèles très rares comme cette peugeot
402 des années 30
cette voiture elle est vraiment
particulière du fait qu'elle a intégré
les collections du musée
suite un donc de la propriétaire qui
était une dame qui devenait très âgés
mais qui a connu cette voiture tout
petit ça arrive souvent des dons oui
alors certaines personnes préférons voir
leur véhicule terminer leur vie au sein
des collections du musée pour pouvoir
pérenniser un petit morceau de leur vie
certaines voitures semblent en attente
de restauration mais elles ne sont là
que pour sauver les autres elle va
servir à quoi cette voiture alors sept
voitures ont la garde parce qu'il ya de
nombreuses pièces qui sont encore
utilisables dans nos restauration on va
venir piquer quelques pièces à droite à
gauche qui sont encore sauvable et on va
les intégrer dans les programmes de
restauration des autres 204 cabriolet de
la marque et celle ci finira là
et c'est si une fois que donnera
vraiment plus rien à récupérer et bien
on jettera les quelques restes pas ce
que je peux vous assurer qu'elle sera
complètement désossés et qu'on
réutilisera tout ce qui est possible de
récupérer sur cette voiture dit peugeot
du passé on en croise souvent sur nos
routes
même loin de ce show le lion garde un
oeil sur ses nombreux rejetons que sont
les clubs de collectionneurs
frédéric régnait consacre beaucoup de
temps à son association dédiée aux 404
il est loin d'être le seul dans le monde
[Musique]
et j'ai en afrique du sud
on a des gens en australie rla deux
adhérents sera lien
des gens qui sont en permanence en
contact avec nous aujourd'hui facile par
internet c'est des gens qui sont ralliés
au club il possède même son propre petit
musée un passionné comme il en existe
beaucoup en franche comté le berceau de
la marque ici sa coupe et 404 et 1964
c'est probablement pour les
collectionneurs le plus beau coupé des
années 60 avec une ligne assez
exceptionnel dessinée par pininfarina
qui reprend complètement la mécanique et
tous les trains roulants de la 404
berline un jour ou l'autre
frédéric se rendra peut-être en
pèlerinage dans ce bâtiment aux noms
étranges terre blanche
l'autre secret du lion
[Musique]
c'est le centre d'archivés du groupe psa
est pour le moment seuls quelques
chercheurs ont physiquement accès à ce
lieu où l'on conserve par exemple les
incroyables étude de style des modèles
citroën être à votre place
avoir parcouru tous ses cd ça c'est
assez exceptionnel
ce sont des documents uniques bien
évidemment à huy date où le tout le
travail des artistes
alors il cite chez citroën on a la même
chose pour peugeot
même si on est un petit peu moins en
terme de nombre on entend également
quelques-uns pour un report
elle se trouve là
la mémoire de peugeot et de citroën dans
cette ancienne usine d'outillage au
coeur d'un site psa qui lui est toujours
en activité
nadine la voix tech la photo de la 504 à
numériser sans tête merci je te fais ça
et je te préviens quand c'est fait
chaque jour une équipe de spécialistes
collecte classe numérise des documents
très variés des films des photos des
affiches on trouve même ici l'acte de
naissance du groupe industriel qu'on est
en 1810 et donc 10 810 c'est le
lancement de l'aventuré industrielle des
peugeot est ce registre en est justement
un témoignage donc services de
comptabilité et on voit bien le 26
septembre 1810 jean pierre peugeot jean
frédéric peugeot et jacques m'a l'air
salin qui injectent chacun dix mille
francs de l'époque dans la société
peugeot frères aînés et jacques maillard
sain et c'est de là qu'on d'actes début
de l'aventuré industrielle de peugeot
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on a un tel niveau de
contenus il nous faut 40 ans pour
pouvoir digitalisées donc c'est un
travail énorme colossal
vous aviez créé spa et le directeur de
l' aventure peugeot citroën ds il est
donc le gardien de ce temple de la
mémoire qui n'est pas ouvert au public
même rien ou un pouvoir donner accès
parce que c'est aussi ça notre mission
donc on invente
des formes de digitalisation qui rendent
du coup les documents accessibles par un
site internet
et c'est comme ça que au fur et à mesure
on donne accès finalement au public tout
ce contenu
[Musique]
quant aux réserves du musée peugeot
inutile de rêver elles resteront fermés
les rares visiteurs qui déambuleront
dans ce lieu magique seront si les seuls
à vivre
c'était un an voyage vers l'enfance
[Musique]